on va chercher bien loin ce que l'on a
bien pris c'est un peu pour empêcher que
se justifie cet adage que deux syndicats
l'initiative de limoges a décidé
d'organiser chaque dimanche des visites
de la ligue
le premier périple dominical était
centre axé sur ce que doit être une cité
moderne avec d'abord des espaces verts
avec les particuliers et de laurence la
capitale régionale
on reste dans la tradition qui a fait du
limousin le pays de l'arbre de l'eau par
excellence et bières anglaises pelouse
platanes chouchen permettent un
dépaysement à deux pas de votre pompe
l'environnement n'est pas le seul aspect
important contre le citadin jouissent
pleinement de ce que le modernisme lui a
apporté pour que ce modernisme ne les
crasses ma le problème de l'eau potable
et du reste tout aussi capital que celui
de la pollution de l'air
c'est pourquoi les touristes du dimanche
ont pu visiter la station d'épuration de
la bâtie la capacité de production de
cette station est de 80 mille mètres
cubes par jour ce qui correspond aux
besoins d'une ville de 200 mille
habitants
le dispatching général permet à l'agent
de service de surveiller la marche de
l'installation et le traitement
reminéralisation heures par décantation
filtration réaction est celui utilisé
par toutes les grandes villes des états
unis
dimanche prochain le voyage autour de ma
ville ou conduira si vous le désirez à
la zup de laurence et à buxerolles
mais d'ici là vous avez la possibilité
de retrouver des paysages familiers à
l'exposition des artistes limousin